[Music]
here's Ruth Wilson as mrs. Coulter in
His Dark Materials acting alongside
puppeteer brian fisher as her demon the
golden monkey fisher has the intricate
and difficult job of walking talking and
even breathing in sync with wilson for
the series production company bad wolf
utilized the talents of puppeteers and
visual effects artists to create over
2,000 shots as well as fifty different
creatures so why go to all this effort
with puppets only to eventually render
the animal in CG and why was it that the
VFX artist needed to wrestle each other
even though the animals look incredibly
real the only animal actor on set
belongs to Lord boreal and is played by
an actual snake this is Russell Dodgson
a senior visual effects supervisor at
frame store who first had to cast the
series looking at different animals that
were play to humans external souls the
demons it was very clear that we wanted
to go for a naturalistic performance for
the demons because we didn't want them
to have any kind of caricaturist or
cartoonish quality to them he worked
with pre and post visualization company
painting practice to look animal
reference images and bought in animal
experts to advise on the creatures
gender and their correct groom and
coloration the VFX team then ran
animation tests in facial rig software
with dog sniffing and monkeys jumping to
try out the facial movement
they realized they needed to perform
dialogue through the animals bodies
instead of just using their mouths and
facial expressions to emot-- so it
always start with the rhythm of their
body and then just add in the lip-sync
because there's almost like the final
touch London saying we've got to get all
of the shape phenome perfect every
single time they speak puppetry legend
William Todd Jones then devised a series
of proxy stand-ins rigs and puppets for
the actors to interact with and this is
where Bryan comes back in for close-ups
some of the puppets were sculpted heads
other slinky body styles a puppet were
used for quadrupedal or bipedal animals
when actors needed to demonstrate the
weight of demons the team made gray
furry cushions called
bucks these had weight and shape to make
it look like actors were holding demons
but why bother with this complex
laborious process proper tearing and
giving the actors something to play off
off was critical because they're not
we're not just making kind of creatures
that chase after people we're making
parts of people you know we're
representing their soul it's really
amazing how you can have a very simple
puppet face and just the way that an act
like a puppeteer just does a little head
[ __ ] and use only just throw emotion
onto it
another advantage of using puppets was
the puppet pass take this scene with
Bryan the scene is blocked with the
puppets so the crew and actors know
whether demon would be they delivered
dialogue or sang to the actors fire the
puppets to rehearse the scene Bryan
makes noises like barks or clicks or
even breathes so Ruth as mrs. Coulter
feels more in tune with her co-star they
shoot the scene once with the puppet and
then with just an eye line or nothing at
all the actor gets so used to having the
puppet sir that they then performed to
the empty space
this allows the director to use the take
with the puppet if the performance is
better as the VFX team could then easily
edit out the puppet and this was often
the case now that's all fine for
something as small as a monkey but the
team had to think bigger for something
is sizable as a polar bear for Europe
and the Bears it was a whole different
story loads of reads for them a
full-size head sculpt was measured so
that there was a stick attached to it
that when the performer Joe Edinburgh
put it on his belly button
it became the right height for your ex
head it gave you the two eyes in the
nose or as a shape and the full volume
at the head which was great because
you're really imposing and you need
someone to feel like there's something
in their space and it wasn't just
creating space that made the puppets so
important puppets assisted the action
when actors needed to be thrown around
the place or physically shifted there
was the basher bear to ram into stunt
people and push actors to the ground
like in this scene with Harry Melling
there was also a riding rig for Daphne
Keane to sit on a backpack rig for her
to get on top of someone's shoulders and
a four legged fibreglass standing puppet
to show a polar bears height but the
team also had to go further than using
this elaborate set of puppetry tools in
order to capture the bears movement
including fighting the VFX team used
their own bodies and wrestled each other
they filmed themselves crackling using
mixed martial arts references as the way
bears wrestle is quite similar to humans
painting practice then built the entire
bear palace in the Unreal Engine game
simulator and the team filmed the fight
in that to live track the set they used
a tool called vanishing point vector
which is a brand new piece of tracking
software it leverages augmented reality
and real-time tracking by placing a
camera sensor on top of the main unit
camera so the Bears were real time on
the viewfinders for the camera operators
we could have made the entire bear
Patterson CG but because we had so much
time
in there with the actors we knew that we
wanted there to be a space with any
technology there's always the chance of
something going wrong or you wanting to
completely adapt to a different thing or
change the animation which you can't do
live there and then so we also then just
bring the puppets out which are kind of
true tested analog way of doing it and
we bring them out and work through that
way then began the painstaking process
of CGI detail for the bears and demons
it took seven hundred days just to make
polar bear Europe Burleson and his armor
amazingly they didn't find bears the
hardest individual animal to make birds
such as a masters demon with some of the
trickiest the point where the wings come
together and interlink is also tricky in
3d a computer finds it difficult to
process them coexisting in a similar
space so the team had to use puppets to
land on actor's arms or takeoff so they
had a better visual reference for the CG
even though you see over 50 puppeteer
and CGI animals in the final product the
amount of demons in the final pass was
limited the big character moments remain
but having too many background animals
was deemed distracting so what you see
is the bare essentials formed ironically
through a painstaking multi Department
process
you